the Mission Impossible 5 trailer is here
are now known as Mission Impossible
rogue nation this film is directed by
Christopher McQuarrie and stars Tom
Cruise ving rhames Simon Pegg and now
I'm a big fan of the mission impossible
franchise my dad showed me the
television show when I was just a kid
I watched the original films of course
in the 90s as well as all the way
leading up to ghost Protocol which was
actually the best one yet and by the
looks of this trailer there seemed to be
retaining that type of vibe that ghost
Protocol set that fun adventure like
vibe as well as comedy infused within it
that's what made ghost Protocol so great
as well as the team aspect of it because
up until then it was really cool seeing
Tom Cruise do awesome stunts and cool
action scenes but the best parts of all
of the Mission Impossible movies
involved the team Christopher McQuarrie
recently worked with Tom Cruise on Jack
Reacher which I really enjoyed as well
and if the way the action scenes were
held in that film are any indication
they're gonna look great and from this
trailer they do look great and I'm so
excited to see the way these action
scenes are strung together and when you
work with an actor like Tom Cruise that
kind of stuff is gonna be easier to do
because he's so dedicated to the stunt
work and dedicated to the audience
having a good time that you can film
these really awesome sequences and not
worry about stunt doubles or showing the
back of an actor's head or some shift so
the rogue nation in this movie is
apparently the anti-imf the organization
that is basically the polar opposite
their enemy and I'm excited to see how
this all plays out I'm so glad Simon
Pegg has returned it's also great to see
ving rhames having a bigger role just
from this trailer the action sequences
they set up look incredible as for
issues with the trailer because this is
about the trailer now not the movie the
trailer does that cliche thing that like
all trailers are doing nowadays where
they get a really slow-mo version of a
classic song and they cover it in some
way san andreas did that with California
dreamin and this movie is doing that as
well it's a trailer thing they're doing
now you know inception days where blah
blah
like that was that that was the big
thing of the inception trailer days and
now it seems like slow-mo covers of
songs that are famous because it's
cheaper to do a cover of a famous song
than just buying the rights to use it I
understand that that's a marketing
technique it's kind of stupid but it
doesn't really say anything about the
finished product of a movie which looks
amazing I'm pumped out of my mind to see
this movie I can't wait to be in the
theatre to do so in fact I'm not gonna
watch any more trailers more than likely
for this because I think I've seen
enough already
it's coming out July 31st I no longer
have to wait to December which is also
awesome so I'm pretty much done with
footage for Mission Impossible 5 to this
point because I've seen enough I don't
need to know anything else and I can't
wait to sit in the theater and enjoy it
what did you guys think of the trailer
for Mission Impossible rogue nation let
me know below also please do check out
my hilarious 'ti review for jaws the
revenge that I just posted I worked very
hard on that and I hope you guys enjoy
it it's just a lot of laughs and if you
guys enjoy that type of thing making it
fun a bad entertainment and check it out
guys it's on my channel right now as
always thank you so much for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stumped in the heist